attention c'est parti toc toc toc
tiens
nabil n'a bien
vive l'amitié
attendait on va leur parler
[Applaudissements]
il
faut les laisser guérir
les orléans leur fait
qu'est
nabil triki
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui auraient été arrêtées selon moi pour
l'instant je ne vous reconnais pas ces
gens
[Applaudissements]
à 18h50 pâle merci mme aubry points
les bulls
voilà
quel bonheur
quel bonheur de voir tes bourreaux ram
ou chérie ouais c'est pas ce qui se
passe plus je vieillis plus je m'en vais
leaf mais je te jure talent et c'est
toujours un petit peu plus long c'est
magnifique c'est vrai ça vous plaît
c'est que j'adore avec ce balayage et je
deviens de plus en plus gris antilles je
vous saurais n'est pas de plus encore
pour moi ça vous dira tout aussi un
fait un break enfin il faut que tu
ailles chez l'ophtalmo
rétention se connaît à ton succès vague
mais c'est vrai que si tu me dis que
c'est mieux qu'avant je me dis mais dans
quel état j'étais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
là avant que tu arrives à tpb la balle
ne sont pas foutus de ma gueule pendant
combien de temps on a tout il y avait
une étude on a tout ici il avait été élu
dans un sondage sérieux dans un arrêt un
gros truc et où le chroniqueur le plus
beau du paf waouh choix c'était plus
sexy dans le plus beau pour moi le plus
c'est que c'est embrouillé ce qui est
bien c'est que personne n'a ri gaulle et
dont il
faut savoir qu'il ya en concurrence y
avait ni nicolas canteloup entre autres
alors maintenant il a son charme mais je
dis pas le contraire mais mais je sais
que ce qui m'avait pouce blessé c'était
la surprise
mais jean luc
tu veux je te dit pas costaud
aujourd'hui je comprends tout à fait
[ __ ] on comprend tout à fait
j'aimerais tellement qu'il fasse encore
ce genre de sondages alors lancé je vais
danser ici commencez vraiment sur lui ça
va super très content de te voir mon
chéri comme bouder alors elle c'est vrai
que vous devez vous avez marqué
l'histoire de thé pmp les deux
fraîchement décédé rigolade jean-luc
bouder incroyable si c'est vrai que
c'est ouf parce que je sais que jean luc
et boudin bouder il nous suit tous les
soirs ils m'envoient des sms tous les
soirs bouder tous les soirs il fait des
petits commentaires sur les missions et
jean-luc je sais qui nous suit aussi et
jean-luc à chaque fois parce que
jean-luc c'est un mec qui adore la télé
et il boit il faut il m'envoie sur les
audiences d'hier c'est au flot durant ce
brave et c'est vrai que je sais que vous
nous suivez énormément tous les deux ça
me fait très plaisir merci mais c'est
vrai que voilà vous n'avez pas bien sur
vous n'êtes plus là mais vous n'avez pas
décrocher complètement non
on a pensé ouvrir une pizzeria tous les
deux
on est resté dans le game là non mais
pas décroché tel complètement que tpm p
non parce que ça soit il ya des liens
c'est ça reste à la famille moi j'y ai
passé sept ans quand même donc il ya des
gens j'ai envie de voir même genre à
s'en faire un visio temps en temps avec
la famille je vois comment ils évoluent
capillairement
c'est vrai c'est vous dire tu nous
regardes depuis avant quand tu étais
dans une autre chaîne direct france qui
avait très très longtemps le dire on
peut le dire la france 4 c'est vrai ça
bof moi j'aime bien le soir on veut dire
et vous regardez d'accord je peux pas
regarder soir jeu vers le lendemain
matin les séries nous regardera alors
bouder on a fait aussi la grosse
rigolade en sahraouis break condor
fasciné tout le monde chaud c'est là je
suis latine en train d'en organiser une
on aimerait en faire une seule y est
entre très vite entre les deux tours des
élections oui quoique ya vraiment
matière à rire entre les deux tours je
pense que oui justement cette map rêve
d'étendre si ça doit c'est là qu'il faut
le faire je pense aux échanges aux
autres hiboux les gens vont avoir envie
de rire elle vous avoir besoin de rire
je pense